oh  the cycle of this world i will not allow  to perish with you  [Music]  i seek to destroy the irrational power  structure that shackles folding  if the kingdom is ever to part ways with  our bloody past  this is the path we must walk  i have ambitions edelgard realized  will you sit around and wait for a  miracle  or will you help me seize control of my  fate  [Music]  we shall fight  we shall survive and we shall win a  glorious future for foodland  now that i know  i won't make the same mistake again  is not a thing you take for someone else  [Music]  you seek revenge to slake your rage and  heal your wounded heart  i know you are prepared to do whatever  that you must  [Music]  you